[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Siri einen schönen guten Abend an
diesem Mittwoch Norbert Lehmann der
stimmt uns später auf den WM
handballkraft
von mir und wir starten die Sendung
heute mit einer lange schwielenden Frage
die jetzt entschieden ist
wir werden der Ukraine
auch Kampfpanzer zur Verfügung stellen
vom Typ Leopard 2 der Bundeskanzler
macht es also offiziell Deutschland
liefert und auch die USA sagen der
Ukraine schwere Panzer zu
besser als befürchtet die Regierung
korrigiert ihre Konjunkturprognose nach
oben die Wirtschaft soll dieses Jahr um
0,2% wachsen
und bereit für Frankreich mit einem Sieg
über den Rekordweltmeister wollen
Deutschlands Handballer heute ins WM
Halbfinale
[Musik]
es ist also entschieden Deutschland
liefert der Ukraine in einem ersten
Schritt 14 Leopard Kampfpanzer und auch
US-Präsident beiden kündigte soeben an
31 Kampfpanzer vom Typ Adams zu liefern
zu deutschen Entscheidungen sagte der
Kanzler heute im Parlament es sei
richtig gewesen dass man sich in dieser
Frage nicht habe treiben lassen bevor
wir gleich näher auf Panzer Details und
Reaktionen eingehen fassen Andreas
Huppert und Lars Boden sagt die
historische Entscheidung und den Tag in
Berlin zusammen
der Bundeskanzler auf dem Weg zur
regierungsbefragung heute kein
Routinetermin Olaf Scholz nutzt ihn um
im Bundestag zu erklären warum
Deutschland jetzt doch der Ukraine
Leopard zweikampfpanzer liefern wird
alle diese Entscheidung haben wir im
Einklang und in enger Kooperation mit
unseren Verbündeten getroffen das ist
der Grund warum sie wirksam sind und
warum wir sie auch treffen konnten das
ist das Prinzip dass diese Regierung hat
Scholz rechtfertigt damit auch sein
langes Zögern es er richtig gewesen sich
nicht treiben zu lassen die die Wiese
bleibe niemals allein denn nur die
Abstimmung mit den NATO-Partnern schütze
vor einer Eskalation mit Russland
vertrauen Sie mir vertrauen Sie der
Bundesregierung wir werden weiter weil
wir international abgestimmt Handeln
sicherstellen dass diese Unterstützung
möglich ist ohne dass die Risiken für
unser Land darüber in eine falsche
Richtung wachsen das ist warum wir das
so tun und so werden wir es auch
weitermachen
vor gut einer halben Stunde der
Bundeskanzler im ZDF-Interview wird
Deutschland durch die
leopard-lieferungen jetzt zur
Kriegspartei von Olaf Scholz dazu ein
klares Nein Nein in keinem Fall und
darum ging es auch zu keiner Zeit
sondern wir haben eine sehr klare Linie
verfeuchten den vielen Monaten seitdem
der furchtbare Krieg Russland gegen die
Ukraine begonnen hatte wir haben sehr
sehr viele Waffen geliefert auch sehr
wirksame mittlerweile sind wir in Europa
zusammen mit Großbritannien diejenigen
die das meiste liefern und das wird sich
noch weiter fortsetzen wir sind da vorne
dran lange wurde dem Kanzler Zögern und
Zaudern vorgeworfen auch aus den Reihen
der Ampelkoalition beeinflussen lassen
wollte er sich davon aber nicht
dass Leute laut rufen dass sie in ihre
Sendung hier ständig jemand kriegt der
mit ernster Mine sagt sehr sofort und
dies noch und das noch und ich verstehe
das nicht dann können Sie jeden Tag 300
von aufbieten und das dann dokumentieren
aber die Bürgerinnen und Bürger wollen
dass jemand regiert der davon sich nicht
beeindrucken lässt aus
Bundeswehrbeständen werden also 14
Leopard 2 A6 für die Ukraine
bereitgestellt außerdem erteilt die
Regierung anderen Nationen die Erlaubnis
die in Deutschland gefertigten Leopard
Panzer Kiew zu überlassen Deutschland
wird immer vorne an sein wenn es darum
geht die Ukraine zu unterstützen wir
sind das Land dass das mit großer
Energie und in großen Umfang tut
Lautstärke kritik gab es heute nur von
der Opposition bei FDP und Grünen
dagegen war nichts mehr zu hören
wir wollen nach Berlin gehen zu Theo
Colt Theo nach fast zwei Wochen
intensiver panzerdebatte heute die
Entscheidung wie bewertest du das
Ergebnis
also wenn wir ehrlich sind dann kann mit
Blick auf den weiteren Kriegsverlauf ja
niemand sagen ob das heute die richtige
Entscheidung war oder nicht rettet sie
die Ukraine vor der russischen
Frühjahrsoffensive oder ist es der eine
Schritt zu viel der dann potent seiner
irrationalen unkontrollierbaren
Eskalation veranlasst der Kanzler meinte
heute es gebe dafür keine mathematischen
Gewissheiten daher auch seine kleinen
Schritte was ich aber bewerten lässt ist
der Weg zur Entscheidung und da zeigen
sich meines Erachtens echte Defizite
auch wenn vieles nur vertrauliche
entschieden werden kann in solch
zentralen Fragen einer Kriegssituation
muss Regierungshandeln erklärt werden
muss die Bevölkerung nachvollziehen
können was warum gemacht wird oder auch
nicht da reicht es dann finde ich nicht
wie der kanzleute forderte vertrauen Sie
mir das wäre eine unangemessene
Forderung die eigene Meinungsbildung zu
delegieren danke Theo bis hierher wir
sprechen gleich noch mal weiter der
aufgewirbelte Staub in der panzerdebatte
hängt noch in der Luft aber insgesamt
wird erleichtert auf die deutsche
Entscheidung reagiert kritisiert wird
allerdings immer noch die späte Reaktion
des Kanzlers ob Deutschlands
internationales Ansehen darunter leidet
fragen wir gleich noch mal in Washington
und Berlin nach zuvor die Reaktionen des
Tages auf die panzerentscheidung von
Dritter Buchholz
Jubel in Polen der Ministerpräsident
sieht die Lieferung als einen großen
Schritt vorwärts um Russland zu stoppen
der Nato-Generalsekretär begrüßt die
deutsche Führung ausdrücklich und der
ukrainische Präsident meldet sich zu
Wort ich bin sehr glücklich ich möchte
Deutschland Großbritannien und den
Vereinigten Staaten danken dass sie
diese Entscheidung getroffen haben
umstritten bleibt aber das Tempo der
Entscheidung die Union wirft im Kanzler
Zögerlichkeit vor der Bundeskanzler hat
die Öffentlichkeit und die Partner über
Wochen und Monate im Unklaren darüber
gelassen warum er denn eine solche
Entscheidung in diesem Umfang verzögert
wichtig ist doch dass wir hier eine
gemeinsame Lösung gefunden haben dass
intensive Diskussionen und
prüfungsprozesse dazu gehören liegt in
der Natur der Sache
FDP und Grüne begrüßen die lange
geforderte leopardlieferung andere Töne
von Linken und AFD
bewertet die Entscheidung als
verhängnisvoll wir leben mit Russland
auf einem Kontinent die USA ist ganz
weit weg und wir machen uns hier ohne
Not zu Zielscheibe und werden hier
wirklich in eine ganz gefährliche
Situation
hineingezogen nun ist aber auch der
stärkste Nato-Partner mit an Bord die
USA sie liefern 31 Kampfpanzer gerade
erst habe beiden mit Scholz und macron
gesprochen
die Erwartung von Russland ist dass wir
aufgeben dass wir nicht zusammenstehen
aber wir sind vollkommen absolut
vereinigt Scholz wollte eine breite
Allianz und die scheint jetzt erreicht
natürlich gibt es verschiedene
Perspektiven auf die heutige
panzerentscheidung sprechen wir darüber
noch mal mit Theo Koll in Berlin aber
zunächst zu Elma teven nach Washington
Elmar es gab ein bemerkenswertes hin und
her zwischen Washington und Berlin vor
einer Stunde bevor US-Präsident beiden
die Einigkeit mit den NATO-Partnern will
auch Panzer liefern wie ist das
einzuschätzen
ja also Präsident beiden hat Deutschland
sehr gelobt aber hinter den Kulissen
hört man dass das Verhältnis schon auch
belastet und angeknackst ist man habe
Berlin eigentlich nie gedrängt in den
letzten 12 Monaten aber umgekehrt habe
genau das Berlin nun mit Washington
gemacht und dabei den Eindruck weg wenn
auch ungewollt dass es vielleicht bereit
wäre zuzulassen das Russland diesen
Krieg gewinnt Amerika möchte dass
Deutschland
Führungsverantwortung übernimmt und
deshalb liefert es jetzt eben diese
Abrams Panzer und hat damit einen
Strategiewechsel erkauft dem alle
zustimmen nämlich dass man umschaltet
von der defensiver auf die Offensive das
Gebiete zurückerobert werden und dass
man am Ende die Ukraine befreit so hat
es Präsident beiden vorhin ausgedrückt
und gewissermaßen sind jetzt die
Lieferungen von Leos Challengers und
Abrams dann das Siegel darauf dass man
sich darauf verpflichtet und das ist
eine Verantwortung aus der so die
Erwartung hier in Washington Deutschland
eben sich auch nicht mehr herausstellen
kann zu der stehen muss ein neues
strateg das Ziel ohne wanken wieder nach
Berlin zu Theo Koll Theo wie viel
Ansehen hat Berlin diese wochenlange
panzerdebatte gekostet
da hängt natürlich in ordentliches
Preisschild dran das zeigen ja sowohl
die Umfragen hierzulande als auch die
internationalen Reaktionen über dieses
sogenannte scholzing der Kanzler war
offensichtlich aber bereit diesen Preis
zu zahlen einerseits weil es seinem Stil
entspricht und andererseits aber auch
weil es ihm so scheint es hier besonders
wichtig ist den engen Schulterschluss
mit den USA zu behalten nicht nur als
Symbol der aktuellen Geschlossenheit
sondern auch mit Blick in die Zukunft in
die Ukraine dürfte ja noch sehr lange
ein hochgerüsteter Front statt bleiben
und nach den nächsten US-Wahlen könnte
der nächste US-Präsident viel weniger
Interesse an der Ukraine haben daher
dann auch das Drängen auf die heute
angekündigten amerikanischen Kampfpanzer
also ein wahrscheinlich gutes Ergebnis
nach einem schwierigen Vorlauf dann
danke nach Berlin und Washington Theo
und Emma vielen Dank in der Ukraine
wurde die Entscheidung zur Lieferung von
Kampfpanzern lange herbeige gesehen
schauen wir uns jetzt noch mal an welche
Zusagen bis jetzt eigentlich gemacht
worden sind zwei bataione Leopard 2
Panzer wollen europäische Länder liefern
das wären insgesamt etwa 90 Stück davon
sollen zunächst 14 aus Deutschland
kommen weitere Panzer Steuern dann wohl
Finnland Spanien die Niederlande Polen
und Norwegen bei zu den Leopard 2 kommen
dann noch 14 britische Challenger und 31
amerikanische Abrams was die Kampfpanzer
strategisch für die Ukraine bedeuten
erklärt Franziska von tiesenhausen
an der Front nahrbach-muth warten sie
sehnsüchtig auf moderne Waffen aus dem
Westen jedes Gerät ist hier im
Dauereinsatz Frost und Minusgrade machen
der Technik zu schaffen diese Technik
wird nicht mehr lange mitmachen sie
versagt dauernd mehrere Geräte werden
gerade repariert aber sie sind so
abgenutzt dass sie schnell wieder kaputt
gehen
dass ein breites Bündnis aus dem Westen
jetzt Panzer schickt für viele Soldaten
eine gute Nachricht auch wenn das erste
Paket nur etwa 130 umfasst und nicht 300
wie vom ukrainischen generalstaatschef
gefordert die Lieferung machen auf jeden
Fall einen qualitativen Unterschied für
die Ukraine weil sie damit ihre Soldaten
besser schützen kann weil sie
hoffentlich UK russische Linien damit
durchbrechen kann und weil sie vor einer
möglichen russischen Offensive besser
geschützt sind bislang kämpft die
Ukraine mit sowjetischen T-72 Panzern
doch die Bestände schwinden Ersatzteile
und Munition sind kaum mehr zu bekommen
das ist bei westlichen Panzern anders
hier können wir die Nachschub an
Munition viel genauer kontrollieren und
auch planen wir können den Ukrainern
genau sagen was sie bekommen können was
nicht das verschiedene Panzertypen
geliefert werden stellt die ukrainische
Armee vor Herausforderungen Ausbildung
Reparatur ersatzteilogistik sind dadurch
komplizierter experten gehen aber davon
aus dass die Ukraine damit umgehen kann
um den Kriegsverlauf entscheidend zu
beeinflussen brauche es allerdings ein
stimmiges Gesamtpaket der Kampfpanzer
macht Sinn zusammen im Gefecht der
verbundenen Waffen mit den
schützenkanzler mit Artillerie also in
einem Paket und dieses militärische
Paket wiederum macht auch Sinn oder ist
sinnvoll zusammen auch mit den
Wirtschaften der wirtschaftlichen
Unterstützung für die Ukraine als Staat
in zwei bis drei Monaten sollen die
ersten Leopard Panzer in der Ukraine
einsatzbereit sein
nach Berlin und Washington wollen wir
nach Moskau gehen zu Vögel gab für
Deutschland und die USA haben heute
entschieden der Ukraine Panzer zu
liefern insgesamt will der Westen ca 130
Panzer liefern was löst das in Russland
aus
ja da war heute eine gewisse Ambivalenz
zur
beobachten die möglichen Auswirkungen
die solche Panzerlieferungen auf den
Kriegsverlauf haben könnten klein zu
reden da war zum Beispiel Kreml Sprecher
pestkopf der sagte wer jetzt meine dass
die Ukraine dadurch einen besonderen
Vorteil erringen würde der überschätze
die Fähigkeiten der ukrainischen Armee
andererseits dann so jemand wie der
russische Botschafter in Berlin der
sagte Deutschland habe mit dieser
Entscheidung den Konflikt auf eine neue
Ebene gehoben das sind deutliche
zugespitzte Worte aber nichts was wir so
oder so ähnlich nicht schon früher
gehört hätten es ist also im Moment
keine Verschärfung der Tonlage zu
erkennen aber bislang gibt es auch noch
keine direkte Reaktion aus dem krämme
dann vielen Dank für die Einschätzung
nach Moskau für
was nun Herr Scholz heißt es bei uns um
kurz vor halb acht also direkt nach
unserer Sendung Fragen an den
Bundeskanzler zu seiner Ukraine Politik
und direkt danach auch noch ein
zdf-spezial zur panzerlieferung
der Ukraine Krieg ist nur ein Grund für
die machen wir hier rein ja okay für die
schwierige Wirtschaftslage wachsende
Inflation und Energiekrise sind die
Folgen trotzdem schaut die
Bundesregierung wieder etwas
zuversichtlicher in die Zukunft und hat
die Prognose für dieses Jahr leicht
angehoben auf ein zartes Plus von 0,2 %.
im Herbst hatte man für dieses Jahr noch
eine Rückgang der wirtschaftlichen
Entwicklung um -0,4% erwartet mehr jetzt
von Karl Hinterleitner
Robert Habeck gab sich heute verhalten
optimistisch die Zahlen des
jahreswirtschaftsberichts besser als
befürchtet man habe die Lage im
Wesentlichen im Griff wir haben uns
Schritt für Schritt aus der Krise
rausgearbeitet wir haben eine neue
Dynamik entfacht wir haben gezeigt dass
Deutschland schnell sein kann und das
ist die Botschaft des Jahres 22
dass wir eine Krise
beherrschbar gemacht haben
so ist bei der Inflation ein Rückgang
von 7,9% im vergangenen Jahr auf 6% in
diesem vorhergesagt besonders die
Energiekrise hat sich entschärft die
Preise für Gas und Öl sind in diesem
Jahr massiv gesunken doch dabei habe man
auch einfach nur Glück gehabt meinen
Experten die Politik reklamiert Erfolge
gern für sich und wenn es schief geht
sind liegt es an widrigen äußeren
Umständen klar ist die milden
Temperaturen waren der Hauptfaktor sie
haben dazu geführt dass der Gasverbrauch
so weit gesunken ist dass wir jetzt gut
über den Winter kommen und auch wenn
sich die Lage auf dem Energiesektor erst
einmal entspannt hat andere langfristige
Probleme bleiben es gibt verschiedene
Herausforderung die wir interessieren
müssen Abhängigkeiten im Handel und auch
bei kritischen Rohstoffen müssen
unbedingt adressiert werden und auch dem
Fachkräftemangel muss entgegengewirkt
werden Fazit eine Bilanz die auch wegen
des milden Winters positiver ausfällt
als erwartet überwunden ist die Krise
damit aber noch nicht
am Nachmittag diese Meldung aus
Schleswig-Holstein in einem Regionalzug
auf der Strecke Kiel Hamburg ist ein
Mann mit einem Messer auf Passagiere
losgegangen kurz vor alt in der Gemeinde
Brokstedt zwei Menschen wurden bei dem
Angriff getötet mehrere verletzt
darunter offenbar auch der mutmaßliche
Täter selbst er wurde am Bahnhof
festgenommen fragen wir jetzt nach bei
Claas Thomsen er ist der nordisch des
Geschehens in Burgstädt was was weiß man
zum Tat ergangen klar
ja das Innenministerium in Kiel hat vor
wenigen Minuten bestätigt dass es sich
um einen Staatenlosen Palästinenser im
Alter zwischen 30 und 35 handeln soll
dass die Identifizierung und auch die
Altersbestimmung so schwierig war könnte
damit zusammenhängen dass seine Papiere
Blut verschmiert gewesen sein sollen er
ist an der Hand verletzt worden und
jetzt im Krankenhaus ein Sprecher der
Bundespolizei sagte mir gerade er habe
dies auch gehört können aber nichts
weiter dazu sagen man muss wohl also
wahrscheinlich auf morgen warten um
nähere Hintergründe zur Tat und zum
Täter zu bekommen dann vielen Dank für
diese Information aus wo steht Klaus
Thomsen
rund 300 Flüge gestrichen am
Hauptstadtflughafen Berlin Brandenburg
hat ein Warnstreik natürlich den Betrieb
dort lahmgelegt komplett und dazu
aufgerufen hatte die Gewerkschaften
Verdi weil es bei den Tarifverhandlungen
für die gut 6000 Beschäftigten nicht
vorangeht viele von ihnen demonstrierten
vor dem Terminal drinnen im ber dagegen
nichts los nur vereinzelt kamen
Fluggäste betroffen von den Ausfällen
waren insgesamt 35.000 Passagiere
der frühere Spitzenschiedsrichter Manuel
Gräfe erhält im Rechtsstreit mit dem
Deutschen Fußballbund eine Entschädigung
der Grund Altersdiskriminierung Gräfe
hatte seine Bundesliga-Karriere im Alter
von 47 Jahren beenden müssen wegen einer
Form DFB entsprechend praktizierten
Altersbeschränkung dagegen hatte Gräfe
geklagt das Landgericht Frankfurt am
Main sprach dem ex-refery nun eine
Entschädigung in Höhe von
48.500 € zu einen Anspruch wieder zu
pfeifen hat Gräfe aber nicht
so Norbert jetzt sind wir beim Sport
ungefähr noch eine Stunde und dann wird
es richtig spannend WM Viertelfinale
steht an und wir sind alle sehr sehr
gespannt Deutschland gegen Frankreich
und hoffentlich konnte Bundestrainer
Alfred gießlers und seine Jungs nach der
ersten Turnier Niederlage am Montag
gegen Morgen Norwegen jetzt wieder
richtig voll aufbauen denn katrinstein
in Danzig ja da muss heute Abend
wirklich alle Stimmen bei dem Top Gegner
oder
ja Norbert Deutschland spielt gegen eine
der besten Mannschaften der Welt
Frankreich
Rekordweltmeister Olympiasieger das Team
gespickt wird hochkarätigen
Individualisten da muss Deutschland sein
bestes Spiel zeigen um gegen diese Bucht
zu bestehen aber alles sind top
motiviert Juri Knorr spricht vom
wichtigsten Spiel seiner Karriere bisher
momentan spielen hier noch Norwegen
gegen Spanien und danach ist dann
Deutschland dran und wir melden uns zum
fünf nach acht hier live aus Danzig ja
danke Katrin dann bis gleich
die deutsche Hockeymannschaft dagegen
hat ihr WM-Viertelfinale in Indien
bereits gewonnen in einem wahren Krimi
kurz vor Spielende führt England 2:0
dann trifft mats grambusch und
anschließend das 2:2 durch seinen Bruder
Tom danach Penalty schießen Torwart
Danneberg hält zweimal ja und wird zum
Mann des Spiels Deutschland sieht mit
4:3 und trifft im Halbfinale auf
Australien
bei der para WM in spanischen essport
hat Mono Skifahrerin Annalena Forster
ihre dritte Goldmedaille verpasst sie
wurde diesmal zweiter dafür hatte Anna
Maria Rieder in der stehende Klassen
alle Grund zum Freunden
die Goldmedaille in der Abfahrt ist der
erste WM-Titel für Anna Maria Rieder in
ihrer noch jungen Karriere nach dem
ersten Durchgang lag sie noch auf Rang 2
doch mit Laufbestzeit im zweiten
Durchgang gewinnt die 22-Jährige das
Rennen mit knapp einer Sekunde Vorsprung
hatte richtig viel Spaß und bin sehr
sehr happy ja
[Musik]
im parabiathlon holt sich die
Sehbehinderte Leonie Walter mit Ihrem
Guide Pirmin Strecker bei der Nordischen
WM in Östersund den zweiten Titel nach
ihrem Sieg im Sprint gewinnt sie nach
fehlerfreier Schießleistung auch das
Einzelrennen über 10 km
seit ihrem 83 alpinen Weltcupsieg
gestern ist Mikaela shiffrin
rekordsiegerin bei den Frauen ja heute
legte sie gleich nach die 27 Jahre alte
Amerikanerin gewann am Kronplatz in
Südtirol überlegen auch den zweiten
Riesenslalom zum Rekord von Inge Max
Denmark bei den Männer fehlen Schiff
drin jetzt nur noch zwei Siege
doch Kamera
danke dir Norbert wir sind bei den
Zahlen vom Mittwochslotto und die
schauen uns jetzt an 6 11 12 20 25 37
und die Superzahl 2 weitere Gewinnzahlen
auf Lotto zdf.de bzw auf der ZDF Text
Seite 557
von Nordwesten ziehen Regen und Schnee
auf könnte heute Nacht also glatt werden
mehr gleich von Katja horneffer und
direkt nach dem Wetter Fragen Bettina
Schausten und eine gelinek was nun Herr
Scholz danach dann das zdf-spezial das
heute journal übrigens ausnahmsweise
gegen 21 Uhr in der Handball Halbzeit
mit Christian Sievers das war es von uns
danke und bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend von Nordwesten zieht Regen
auf der am Boden auch gefrieren kann
dieses Glätte Band erreicht bis morgen
früh Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
Niedersachsen und Nordrhein-Westfalen
sonst ist die Nacht meist trocken und
die Temperaturen sinken auf Werte
zwischen +2 Grad an der Nordsee und -8
Grad am Alpenrand und morgen liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen an den Alpen um minus
zwei Grad und an der Nordseeküste bei
Plus 8 Grad auch morgen Vormittag kann
es erstmal noch glatt sein hier im
südlichen Niedersachsen und in
Nordrhein-Westfalen aber Schnee und
Regen lassen bald nach und dann ist es
mit der Glätte vorbei ganz im Gegenteil
es kommt sogar zum Teil die Sonne raus
besonders im Südwesten aber auch an der
Nordseeküste da zeigt sie sich häufiger
bei Nordwestwind in den nächsten Tagen
geht es winterlich weiter hin und wieder
mit einigen Schneeschauern aber auch mit
Sonne guten Abend